in many cultures a person existing
outside the to accepted genders is seen
as confronting even threatening but
gender is defined by culture and on
south sulawesi the Bugis believe that in
addition to men women and basu there are
two more these two additional genders
are made up of people who in the West
would be considered transvestites taboos
gender is chalahe why biologically she's
female but she lives as a man I feel
comfortable as cello lie my family is
also comfortable they'll kick him yeah
as long as I'm a good person and I work
hard people accept me Abdul Rahman or
poppy is Chalabi he has male genitalia
but has lived as a woman since he was
six years old we've got a saya
I'm not special the Bugis culture
accepts all five genders
Tambu and papi joined the fertility
ceremony because according to high
priest poema TOA all five genders must
coexist for there to be universal
harmony
there are five genders and we don't need
to separate people based on their gender
because everything must live in harmony
Wow
Vanessa no procedure if one of the
genders are separated then the world
would become unbalanced
at a sacred cave three miles from see
Gary the bazoo begin the first stage of
the blessing an offering to the earth
the boogies believe the universe has
three levels heaven where Pato tail is
the middle world where humans live and
the underworld where the spirits live
you know without a lot there no quit
that along we prove it everything
animals plants people everything stays
connected with each other not only from
this village or the district but the
whole country
the whole world is kept in balance
unsafe by animal and annoying the second
stage of the blessing is an offering to
the spirits because of their be su
gender the Bugis believe that Bisou
priests can communicate with them hawawa
TOA must be possessed by a spirit from
the underworld before the fertility
ritual can be completed in order for
basu to be able to restore particular
blessings they have to be able to
contact the spirit world and part of the
reason they can contact the spirit world
is because they are male and female
embodiment and then the basu with all of
those combinations of female male
spiritual powers can bestow a very
strong blessing